Secretary of State Anthony blinkin and
Homeland Security secretary Alejandra
mayoras are set to meet with the
president of Mexico tomorrow it comes as
8,000 migrants head towards our Southern
border it is the biggest Caravan so far
this year and it's growing Griff Jenkins
spoke with the activist accompanying the
Caravan and he joins us now Griff good
morning to you what did he say to you
well good morning and his name is LS
vagon and he has been organizing
Caravans ever since I went for Fox and
covered and traveled 7,000 miles through
both Honduras Guatemala all of Mexico
this Caravan just left to Chula which is
on the southernmost part of Mexico with
the border with Guatemala and he
organized one in 2018 2019 and several
cents and he believes that uh migrants
should have a path to the US and the US
should do more to help migrants from
countries where there is this credible
fear threat and this Caravan of 8,000
may be larger because as they go through
Mexico more will gather up because
remember there's a pipeline full of
migrants it's not just the 1 8,000 we
get five six uh 10,000 a day uh all
across the border but this Caravan is
largely Cubans and Haitians countries
with which we have offered TPS temporary
protective status various times and
Honduran not so much there with the TPS
thing but there he wants to get
ultimately close to Mexico City where my
orcus and blinkin will feel pressure
there's migrants on the way and they
want to see the US extend more
opportunities for migrants to to come to
the US well I was reading that this
Caravan they're holding signs that say
Exodus from poverty so he's talking
about credible fear threats but that
shows that a lot of these people are
coming to the United States for economic
reasons and I believe that he's the same
guy who told the BBC I thought this
quote was so interesting he said the
problem is that the southern border with
Guatemala is open and 800 to 1,000
people are crossing it daily if we don't
get out of tapachula the town will
collapse so even he leading this group
of illegal immigrants is acknowledging
that they're causing a major economic
problem in southern Mexico and he's also
talking about the fact that the border
between Mexico and Guatemala is wide
open it is and literally uh there's a
river the suat river separates Guatemala
and Mexico there and they literally pay
like 5 10 pesos to cross on a raft and
they're there and there's literally no
Mexican immigration police there to stop
them and in the town of tapula which has
become this hub for my
they don't allow them to work they'll
set up in the streets and try and make
ends meet before they ultimately make
their Journey North to the US but here's
the here's the dirty secret and here
needs to be the focus of mycus and
blinken's conversations with Mexico and
that is Mexico is a Transit country they
want the migrants who all want to go to
the US to get jobs to just move them
quickly moving along move quickly
through but so many have descended on
top Chula because that's where they
start that it's become an economic drag
on top Chula itself which is a pretty
big city in in southern Mexico and so I
think what you're going to see is
activists like vagon become louder and
louder because they've got leverage here
because they're putting pressure on the
Mexican Government which by the way is
out of money the inm the Mexican
immigration folks they've run out of
money that's that's part of the reason
why they're not helping so much so blink
and my orcus are going to lean on Mexico
to try and do more even though they're
out of resources while our border
resources are stretched to points we've
never seen before okay so what is your
expectation for this meeting between
myus uh blinkin and uh myus blinkin and
uh and the Mexican president excuse me
yeah oor well I think o look oor is is
going to is outgoing he's done after his
six years and under the Trump
Administration we threatened very harsh
economic yeah good relationship obor and
Trump this Administration has not
threatened that and I think obor is
going to ask for the us to do do more in
the way of granting Asylum to migrants
like Cuba Haiti Venezuela right they're
all coming from countries that the US
has no repatriation agreements with
although we've begun to send some back
to Venezuela under a special agreement
but I think oor is going to do
everything he can to keep them moving
like I said as quickly as possible so
that they don't become a drag on
Mexico's economy in the US by the way we
were reporting last week the center for
immigration studies put out that three
and five 50 9% of illegal alien
households are on welfare in the US so
Mexico doesn't want that problem with
the illegal aliens in their country so
if just final question here but if this
is becoming if illegal immigration is
becoming a drag on the Mexican economy
then why doesn't obor just shut down
their the southern border between Mexico
and Guatemala it seems like such a
simple solution because he doesn't have
the resources and he doesn't want to do
something he doesn't have the border
patrol resources he no he doesn't have
the resources internally to do it and
and that's In fairness to Mexico to make
that point But ultimately there's also
the political part of it which is he
doesn't want to see be seen as being
negative towards these migrants he wants
to be the you know Open Arms we welcome
you on your journey not to Mexico to the
US yeah the Mexican political
calculation is an important part of the
story that's never discussed so
interesting to hear uh you know so much
about it cff I've spent a lot of time
yeah you certainly have in the in the
first Caravan the migrants called me the
elingo PUO which is basically someone
that would move the Caravan along and
I'll tell you by the way a final point
and that is uh Ain Cabo Mexican
independent journalist I spent a lot of
time with in in uh Eagle Pass a few
weeks ago he's interviewed a lot of the
migrants on the Mexican side and he says
none of them mention credible fear all
of them mention jobs well it's a complex
topic but you cover it so well GFF thank
you stay right there because we're going
to talk about Christmas in a little bit
but I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis